surprise à quelques mois de l'élection
la facture pour couvrir la tournée
électorale du parti conservateur
s'annonce beaucoup moins salée que par
le passé on va assurer que nous pouvons
envoyer notre message les journalistes
qui suivent les chefs assume tous les
frais du voyage et il paye directement
au parti
les coûts pour le transport et l'espace
de travail en 2015
les conservateurs avaient facturé 70
mille dollars par journalistes pour la
campagne
cette fois ci ils devront débourser
seulement onze mille cinq cents dollars
ce qui équivaut à un peu moins de deux
semaines en 2015
en comparaison poursuivre le npd cet
automne il en coûtera 45 mille dollars
de leur côté les libéraux n'ont toujours
pas dévoilé les couleurs campagne la
différence entre ces prix inquiète cet
ancien stratège néo-démocrate
elle craint que seuls les partis aux
coffres bien garnis deviennent plus
accessibles aux médias
d'autant que cette couverture a une
énorme influence sur le choix des
électeurs
cette situation pourrait soulever des
préoccupations éthiques mais l'éclat
qu'il nous manque de l'information
actuellement pour bien évaluer la
situation pour bien évaluer s'il s'agit
d'une quelconque forme de financement ou
de subventions les conservateurs
assurent qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
subvention ou d'un rabais par contre il
n'y a pas de moyen de vérifier
exactement combien coûte suivre un chef
pendant les élections onpe aucune
obligation sous la loi est à risque à
nadal qui obligent des parcelles ou
fournée hanté rapport aussi détaillé ce
professeur de journalisme à l'uqam voit
tout de même la situation d'un bon oeil
pour le grand public y ait d'autres
journalistes dans un autobus pour
couvrir un chef
peu importe le chef plutôt que trois
quatre journalistes beaucoup plus de
questions pointues beaucoup plus de
comptes qui vont devoir être rendu par
les politiciens donc dans cette mesure
là je pense est une bonne chose
il plaide pour un meilleur encadrement
afin de rendre les campagnes électorales
plus accessible
alors que les médias peinent à garder la
tête hors de l'eau
ici fait vincent choisi radio canada
ottawa